-Thank you very, very much.
Welcome, welcome, welcome
to "The Tonight Show"!
You're here.
You made it.
Thank you for watching.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you.
Let's get to some news, guys.
Tonight, President Biden
attended a big
Democratic fundraiser
in Las Vegas.
Yep, not really
the best timing for Biden.
Yesterday, he assured us
the banking system is safe,
and 24 hours later,
he rolled up in Vegas.
[ Laughter ]
He's like,
"Putting it all on black."
[ Laughter ]
Anyway, long story short,
Caesar's Palace
now owns Rhode Island.
So, no big deal.
[ Laughter ]
No, it's all right.
Some more political news.
Last night,
former president Trump
made a campaign visit to Iowa,
and he delivered a speech that
lasted an hour and 45 minutes.
[ Laughter ]
Hour and 45 minutes.
Only Trump can make the Oscars
feel like a TikTok.
[ Laughter ]
Not only did Trump --
Not only did Trump
talk for almost two hours,
but he actually ended his speech
by taking questions
from the audience.
Which backfired
when the first question was,
"Can we go home now?"
[ Laughter ]
Yep, Trump did a Q&A.
He looked at the teleprompter,
said, "Okay.
Now it's time for the Qanda."
[ Laughter ]
"Now it's time for the Qanda."
"It's Q&A."
"I love 'Black Panther.'
Qanda forever.
I've always said --"
[ Laughter and applause ]
"I love Qanda.
Some people celebrate Qanda,
some people don't."
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Q&A."
Meanwhile,
ahead of his speech in Iowa,
Trump said that Florida governor
Ron DeSantis
is "probably" his biggest rival
for the Republican
presidential nomination.
Trump said his only other rivals
are the Justice Department
and high cholesterol.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, and this made me laugh.
When asked if he regretted
endorsing Ron DeSantis
for governor in 2018,
Trump said, and I quote...
[ Laughter ]
"Uh, yeah, maybe,
probably, yeah."
And he didn't stop there.
He went onto say...
[ Laughter ]
Then he said...
And finally, he said...
♪ No, no-no, no, no ♪
♪ Maybe! ♪
[ Applause ]
That's a direct quote.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you, Roots.
Did you guys see this?
Pope Francis suggested
that he's open to reviewing
the Catholic church's
vow of celibacy for priests.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
That should definitely liven up
the next season
of "The Bachelor."
[ Laughter ]
You'll know a decision
has been made when white smoke
billows from
the Tinder headquarters.
[ Laughter ]
Some business news --
amid a rise in shoplifting,
Lowe's is using a new 400-pound,
egg-shaped security robot
to patrol parking lots
at some of their stores.
Here it is.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
400 pounds and egg-shaped.
The robot was like,
"Thanks. Uh, that description
is a real ego boost."
[ Laughter ]
Can we see that thing again?
Wow.
It looks like if R2-D2,
a stormtrooper,
and the "Jeopardy!" buzzer
had a baby.
[ Laughter ]
Yep, they're having robots
patrol the parking lots.
Listen, if I wanted to go
to a hardware store
with no human employees,
I'd go to Home Depot.
-Hey! Oh!
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Hey, guys --
-[ Laughing ]
[ Laughter ]
Almost.
-I read that Kraft-Heinz
is delivering new Lunchables
directly to school cafeterias
across the country.
-Oh.
-Every divorced dad is like,
"Oh, but when
I give it to them..."
[ Laughter ]
"Don't forget -- two Lunchables
counts as a dinnerable."
[ Laughter ]
I think it'll be good
for kids in school,
'cause if there is leftover ham,
they could use it
as a pencil eraser.
[ Laughter ]
Guys, it is Tuesday.
It's time for "WeTweet."
Here we go, everybody.
-♪ WeTweet ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ WeTweet ♪
-Welcome to "WeTweet."
This is where we --
we as a group,
decide something
that we should post on Twitter.
I'm going to show you
five different tweets,
and we're all going to vote on
whether you like each one
or not.
Y'all have voting clickers
at your seats.
It's the biggest and the highest
in technology, right there.
Yeah. You can vote for them.
The green says you like it,
red says you don't like it.
Or you don't have to vote
if you feel like just
sitting back and relaxing.
It's up to you. We're going to
see the results live.
And, Higgins, Roots,
do you have clickers, too?
-Got it.
-And whatever tweet gets
the most likes,
we're going to tweet it out
live during the show so that you
can all like it and WeTweet it.
[ Audience ohs ]
Alright, here we go.
You guys ready for this?
[ Cheers and applause ]
And remember, no standing
ovations in any of these.
-Really?
-Yeah, you just either
like them, you press them.
You can laugh.
Yeah, we like audible.
We like to hear
you laughing as Well --
-But don't stand up.
-Now we just heard
from the judges,
you're allowed to stand up.
-Oh, okay.
-Yeah, yeah.
Okay, the first tweet is...
♪♪
"Uh, sir. Sir, could you please
put your shirt on and...?"
"I appreciate that respect."
Here we go.
The results are in.
Let's see the votes.
No. No.
Didn't like it at all.
People were upset.
That upset people.
-Yeah.
-That bummed people out.
"Sir, I'm going to have to ask
you to leave for not voting."
[ Laughter ]
Alright,
this next one here says...
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Stop looking at me.
Alright.
Let's see the results
on this one.
I think it's going to be better
than the first one.
[ Cheers and applause ]
There you go!
That's the one. That's it.
Almost -- Almost got
one standing ovation.
-Really?
-One girl almost stood up.
-Almost stood up.
-She stopped herself
halfway through.
Yep. Alright.
How about this next one here?
It says...
[ Laughter ]
-Ha!
♪♪
-Deep cut.
-That's a deep cut.
That's for the deejays
out there.
Alright, I think --
-I think it's a good one.
-Yeah. But can it beat --
-No.
-No, I don't think
it's going to beat 157.
Quest, you don't think so,
right?
-It's good, though.
-It's good though, yeah.
Let's see the results.
Oh, wow!
-Wow.
Wow!
-Wow. Shocking.
-88 and full of hate.
-It got a sit--
sitting ovation, that one.
-Wow.
-Let's try the next one.
It says...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow, that almost got one.
-Yeah. I think so.
-Acai!
-Can I vote twice?
Acai!
[ To tune of
"Dragostea Din Tei" ]
♪ Aca-ee, aca-eye ♪
♪ Aya-ee, aya-ah-ha ♪
[ Drum roll ]
Acai, let's see the results.
-Whoa!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Cheering, laughing ]
♪♪
-Oh, my goodness!
Wow.
-Yeah.
Why would we even do
another one?
[ Laughter ]
You won't get better than that.
-We're not going to get --
we might.
-Well, we could get
much lower than the first.
-That's true.
-Let's see how low we can go.
[ Light laughter ]
Let's see
if the red clickers work,
just to make sure
it's not rigged.
'Cause that one, I think
that one should be the hit.
-Yeah, so you're saying
let's try on this one,
to everybody vote no
and see what happens.
-You can't tell everyone
what to do.
-Okay. You do whatever you want.
-But we can also prove
that the system is not rigged
by all voting "no" on this one.
-Right, sure. Right.
-And then you see
if it's rigged or not.
Although we could
edit it in post
and make the audience at home
think that we did this.
But I would never do that.
[ Laughter ]
-We could also edit in some
standing ovations, too.
-Yeah. No, there hasn't been
one standing ovation at all.
We could vote "no" on this, and
then have a standing ovation.
-Vote "no" and standing ovation.
Yes!
-Alright. This might happen.
This has never happened.
We get zero of the votes, so
either don't vote or vote red.
-Right.
[ Laughter ]
-Why are we going this?
-Keep it interesting.
-Last one is...
♪♪
-Oh, the humanity.
Wow.
I don't think
you had to even tell them.
-No, there's a couple people
I can tell voted "yes"
just to...
[ Laughter ]
Let's see the results.
Are we getting a standing ova--
[ Laughter ]
Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughs ] No!
No! It's no!
It's not absolutely no.
[ Laughs ]
I love it.
25 people voted yes.
There we go. We have a winner!
It's number four!
The one with acai.
Way too many syllables.
I'm gonna post this during
the commercial break.
If you see it on your feed,
give it a like.
Give it a WeTweet.
Thank you to those 25 people.